[Music]  I've decided to tell you my life story  it all starts  this was the deciding moment in my life  for a poor kid from the streets of  Acapulco the way to a better life was a  job at Las Colinas the most glamorous  Resort  [Applause]  [Music]  my family just has the one chair  this is where all the action is one  mistake in your career here will be  always good luck  so I just started filming until a dog is  that normal here more normal than you  think  Maximo if you want to keep this shop  maybe don't hate on the boss's  girlfriend  I have this idea what I feel like  working at a place like this but I'm not  sure I feel comfortable here  foreign foreign  [Music]  [Music]  don't worry  who are you